nightlife also making a comeback on the
las vegas strip one major venue
reopening this weekend is the omnia
nightclub over at caesar's palace
but of course it's going to look a lot
different at least for now 8 news now
reporter orc omana gives us a sneak peek
the omnia nightclub will function more
like a lounge with guests
only allowed here on this outdoor
terrace and limiting the number of
people at each of these tables
is just one of the safety measures that
will be put in place
everything is at least six foot apart a
socially distant night on the las vegas
strip we'll have plexiglas put up in
between each group
the omnia terrace which normally fits a
thousand people will only have about 300
because of capacity limits there will
also be touchless menus and intense
cleaning we want everybody to have a
good time but we also have to make sure
that everybody is safe
and that we are complying with the
governor's orders to the letter of the
law
we're very very glad to be back after a
year of being closed james allgate with
hakkasan group tells me the company has
brought back employees to omnia who are
working hard ahead of friday night's
reopening
and business looks promising we've more
or less sold out for the whole opening
weekend there's only a few
limited reservations left
[Music]
although the classic club experience is
not available yet visitors tell us
they're still excited
it's fun to at least get the little
experience you know even if it's
not the same you know as before but i
mean it's something you know they're
they're giving us something back that we
haven't had now that that club's opening
up we'll probably
see if we can go and have a good time
for now it's one step at a time
we'll be ready to rock and roll very
excited omnia will be open on fridays
and saturdays starting at 10 30 p.m and
reservations are required
reporting at cesar's palace on the las
vegas strip orca mana 8 news now